bonsoir bonsoir à tous et bienvenue ça
vous regarde en direct ravi de vous
retrouver au programme ce soir vous le
voyez le président de l'alcra Mario
stasie bonsoir et merci d'être notre
grand témoin l'alcra qui porte plainte
pour apologie du terrorisme contre des
propos tenus sur les réseaux sociaux
après l'attaque terroriste du ramas
contre Israël on va en reparler
évidemment l'importation du conflit
évidemment la recrudescence de
l'antisémitisme sont dans tous les
esprits on va en parler tout à l'heure
notre grand débat ce soir sur le Proche
Orient qui s'enfonce dans l'horreur
climat de terreur en israële bilan
humain qui s'alourdit Gaza sous les
bombes en état de siège et une minute de
silence qui était observé à l'Assemblée
à la mémoire des victimes israéliennes
mais l'unité nationale a été rompue par
la position de la France insoumise nous
en débattrons enfin ns affanchi ce soir
l'économie avec Olivier babo l'air du
temps avec Thomas Lestavel et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée raconté par Stéphanie des
piierres voilà pour le programme on y va
Mario stasie ça vous regarde c'est
[Musique]
parti la représentationation la
représentation nationale donc debout
c'est l'image du jour à l'Assemblée vous
le voyez minute de silence cet
après-midi en mémoire des victimes des
attaques terroristes du ramasse en
Israël solidarité et soutien
inconditionnel à l'État hébreu dans
cette épreuve a déclaré en préambule yel
brun pivé la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale alors que la première ministre
a pris plusieurs fois la parole on
l'écoute Israël a droit à la sécurité
droit de se défendre rien ne peut
excuser le
terrorisme pensez se tourne à voilà on
va évidemment revenir sur cette séance
de question au gouvernement
particulièrement lourde ettendu puisque
vous le voyez les députés de droite ont
boycotté la prise de parole de Mathilde
Panau la chef de fil des insoumis en
quittant l'hémicycle avec le
rassemblement national avant d'être
suivi par une partie de la majorité
bonsoir Christopher weisberg bonsoir
merci à vous d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance des Français qui résident
aux États-Unis vous êtes secrétaire du
groupe d'amitié France Israël et
président du groupe d'études sur
l'antisémitisme à l'Assemblée bonsoir
Rodrigo Arenas ravi de vous accueillir
député la France insoumise de Paris vous
étiez je crois le seul insoumis à la
manifestation parisienne dans le 16e
arrondissement au soutien à Israël hier
soir vous avez publié une lettre à vos
camarades qui condamnent clairement ces
attaques on va y revenir dans le détail
bonsoir offer bronsteinons merci d'être
là président du Forum international pour
la paix vous êtes franco-palestinien
pardon israélo-palestinien pardon et
ancien conseiller du Premier ministre
israélien Isaac Rabine enfin bonsoir
Christian macarian bonsoir ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau vous êtes
éditorialiste international au point et
à Radio Classique Mario stadi évidemment
vous êtes partie prenante la Licra s
déjà beaucoup exprimé depuis l'offensive
de samedi matin n'hésitez pas à
interroger intervenir dans ce débat je
vous propose qu'on commence par la
situation sur place les les dernières
24h la repost sera d'une intensité
jamais connue a promis le premier
ministre benjamine netanahou on voit
cela tout de suite dans le chrono de
blackakovski Stéphane blackakowski qu'on
accueille tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane je me
retourne pour vous accueillir comme
chaque fois bonsoiram pardon bonsoir
messieurs voilà triste journée à nouveau
alors il y a une chose en tout cas qui
m'a frappé ce matin puisque on me
demandait de faire un point sur la
situation c'est cette prise de parole
d'un porte-parole de la armée
israélienne vous allez voir qui disait
alors que donc l'attaque a déjà eu lieu
il y a plus de 3 jours que l'armée
israélienne a plus ou moins repris pris
le contrôle de la frontière donc on en
est pas totalement sûr il y a aussi des
incertitudes d'ailleurs qui planent pour
le bilan on a des estimations sait qu'il
y a plus de 1000 morts du côté israélien
sans doute autour de 150 otages mais il
y a pas de bilan officiel précis
définitif donc ça montre à quel point
Israël a été déstabilisé mais Israël a
déjà réagi d'une part en déclenchant un
blocus total de Gaza donc ça vise
l'électricité et l'eau mais aussi
l'alimentation le carburant puis aussi
une réaction militaire vous avez sans
doute vu les images de frappe des
centaines de bombes ont été lâché sur
les positions du Hamas à à Gaza on
estime qu'il a environ 800 morts et
pourtant Benjamin netanahou a dit hier
soir ce n'était que le début de
l'opération puisque le but affiché est
d'éradiquer le Hamas on écoute Benjamin
netaniaahou nous avons toujours su qui
était le Hamas maintenant le monde
entier le sait le Hamas et
daesh et nous le vaincrons tout comme le
monde instruit a vaincu
daesh cet ennem voulait la guerre et il
l'obtiendra sauf que pour éradiquer le
Hamas on pourra sans doute pas se
contenter de frapp arien comme le fait
Israël pour l'instant euh il y a des
caches souterraines des tunnels qui dans
lesquels le Hamas pourrait dissimulé
donc il faudra une opération terrestre
vraisemblablement ce qui rend d'autant
plus crédible cette opération c'est que
ce weekend Israël a déc déclaré la
mobilisation de 300000 soldats qui
constitue les tris/4s de son armée de
réserve d'ailleurs ce matin
l'ambassadeur de d'Israël en France
jugeait cette tion terrestre quasiment
inéluctable on écoute vousembl encore
des milliers de missiles et de roquettes
dans la bande de Gaza quiue à être lancé
tous les jours sur notre territoire sur
sur nos populations donc ça c'est il
faut des forces terestes pour cela et
puis on peut pas laisser les
commanditair de C des atrocités que nous
avons vu ces derniers jours et en
impunité alors évidemment en cas
d'opération terrestre la question qui se
pose c'est comment va réagir le Hamas
avec la centaine d'ottage dont il
dispose d'autant que hier il a déjà
proféré des menaces en disant qu'il
allait exécuter des otages en cas de
frappe sans préavis des israéliens sur
Gaza en précisant d'ailleurs que ces
exécutions sielles avaient lieu seraient
diffusé sur les les réseaux sociaux donc
forcément en cas de d'attaque terrestre
la vie des otages serait d'autant plus
menacé puis'il y avait cette grosse
opération terrestre il y a un autre
risque pour ça faut montrer une carte
pour le comprendre ça serait que la
milice du Hezbolah qui est une milice
largement soutenue par l'Iran qui est
installé au sud du Liban et donc à la
frontière nord d'Israël une milice
encore plus puissante militairement que
le Hamas pourrait donc ouvrir un second
front en se lançant l'attaque ce qui
obligerait les Israéliens donc à se
répartir sur deux fronts en
effaiblissant leur attaque sur Gaza je
viens juste de parler de l'Iran
puisqu'on parlait du hzbolah c'est l'une
des questions suspens sur lequel je
voudrais conclure ce matin le président
Macron disait que on n pas de preuve que
l'Iran a participé réellement à cette
attaque du Hamas mais on est un peu près
sûr en tout cas c'est vraisemblable
qu'il y a eu une aide et l'Iran est bien
sûr le premier suspect sur sur la liste
si ça se confirmait si les services de
renseignement on étaient sûr farait
guêter bien sûr la réaction d'Israël
même la réaction des Américains qui ont
un énorme porteavion qui s'est installé
sur zone voilà je essayé de faire le
point sur les différents aspects de la
situation mais on a besoin d'experts
pour rentrer dans les détails donc merci
beaucoup Merci à VOUS Stéphane offer
Bronstein je sais que vous dormez
quasiment plus depuis samedi matin plus
de 1000 morts 2600 blessés des dizaines
de disparus dont des Français il y a
déjà h Franco israéliens qui sont morts
expliquez-nous vous avez évidemment
beaucoup d'interlocuteurs en ligne dans
quel état d'esprit sont les Israéliens
est-ce qu'il y a de la rage est-ce qu'il
y a de la colère est-ce qu'il y a de
l'horreur de la sidération 3 jours après
qu'est-ce qu'ils ressentent tout d'abord
permettez-moi de vous m'avez présenté
comme tant un francoisraelo Palestinien
ce soir je suis à 100 % israélien
et je crois que les israélien ressentent
tout ce que vous avez décrit à la fois
de la colère à la fois de la tristesse à
la fois de l'angoisse voir une ville
comme téaviv où on peut trouver un
restaurant ouvert à 4h du matin
contrairement à Paris être complètement
une ville fantôme c'est du jamais vu les
peu de restaurants qui sont ouverts ou
les bars c'est pour préparer des des
repas pour les 300 300 et quelque chose
de milliers de sold cette attaque
terroriste en elle-même massive on a vu
plusieurs points de la frontière avec
Gaza qui ont été percés on a beaucoup
parlé de de ce mur électronique qui n'a
pas été manifestement suffisamment
solide pour pour être efficace des bébés
tués des vieillards kidnappés des femmes
violées des décapitations on a vu ça
aujourd'hui au kibou de de Kaza on a
retrouvé plus de de 100 morts cette
barbarie là c'est du jamais vu c'est pas
seulement c'est du jamais vu pas
seulement au niveau israélien je crois
que c'était jamais vu au monde de qu'
qu'en 24 heures il y
ait une massacre un massacre de cette
envergure euh les défaillances du
service de renseignement et de l'armée
israélienne seront vérifié par une
commission d'enquête je suppose plus
tard et certains vont payer de leur de
leur carrière de leur de leur vie
politique comment le ramas est organisé
apparemment il était très très bien
organisé mais mais ce que je voudrais
signaler c'est que c'est la première
fois depuis l'existence de l'État
d'Israël qu'il y ait une une guerre à
l'intérieur d'Israël toutes les guerres
qu'Israël a mené s'est trouvé à sa
frontière c'est la première fois
qu'Israël est touché dans son cœur et
pas seulement ça il y aura pour moi et
c'est évident que pour pour pour tous
les Israéliens un avant 7 octobre et un
après 7 octobre la société ne sera plus
là M on a parlé de pogrome on a parlé de
septembre c'est c'est un un 11 septembre
magnitude de 20 euh le choc il n'est pas
seulement psychologique le le vous savez
ces jeunes qui ont été massacrés c'estes
kibutsim autour de Gaza c'est ils sont
tous de la gauche israélienne c'est tous
des militants pour la paix et si le
Hamas à la rigueur attaque des soldats
israéliens je peux
comprendre je n'accepte pas la violence
mais je peux comprendre la logique mais
là sacré des jeunes décapiter des des
enfants c'est c'est le Hamas est le plus
grand ennemi des palestinien on va en
parler du ramas justement on entend le
président Benyamin netaniiaou dire ramas
égal daesh la presse vous l'avez regardé
évidemment la presse israélienne pas
seulement la gauche d'ailleurs la presse
de droite israélienne est singlante avec
le Premier ministre et le gouvernement
c'est il est de toute façon affaibli
après ce qui s'est passé selon vous
c'était c'est le capitaine du bateau euh
il y a une responsabilité vous savez le
le le le le Premier ministre israélien
est responsable directement des service
de renseignement et c'est lui le patron
de de en fin de compte de l'armée et
donc il y a des responsabil c'est lui
qui a failli je pense qu'il y a pas il y
a pas que lui qui a failli mais je ne
veux pas rentrer dans des spéculations
les Égyptiens disent qu'ils l'ont averti
les services de renseignement disent
qu'ils en ont parlé je ne sais pas ce
que je sais c'est que c'est lui qui est
au qui est au manette euh tout un
système a failli tout un système qui
s'est complètement écroulé l'armée la
plus puissante des plus puissantes du
monde des services de renseignement qui
sont exceptionnels des moyens
technologiques qui sont uniques au monde
et tout ça il y a 2000 personnes qui
rentrent en même temps par 22 points de
d'entrée par la par la terre par la mer
et par l'air c'est le temps de les
enquêtes viendra Ding c'est pas l'heure
des enquêtes Rama c'est daesh dit
netaniaou Christian macarion vous êtes
d'accord avec ça oui le Hamas a pratiqué
une sorte de coupécollé de toutes les
performances entre TR 13 pa de guet
hyper
terroristes des 20 dernières années on y
trouve des traces
de de daesh évidemment mais d'abord il y
a un surgissement qui provoque cette
sidération on a parlé du 11 septembre
tout à l'heure qui qui relève de ce que
Ben Laden avait imaginé donc il y a
quelque chose comme ça il y a daesh dans
l'hyperterrorisme dans le caractère
sanguinaire sans aucune pitié plus aucun
principe plus aucun contenu même
islamiste parce que là-dessus euh tout
est est chamboulé et puis il y a aussi
quelque chose qui relève de
l'hyperterrorisme utilisé en Europe et
spécialement en France au Bataclan
c'estàdire qu'on attaque une rave partie
et des jeunes qui comme l'a dit Monsieur
Brunstein sont tous pour la paix ils
sont pas du camp de l'affrontement et
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé à
Paris donc si vous
agitionnez Al-Qaïda daesh le Bataclan
vous avez encore sûrement à mon avis et
c'est ça que je trouve le plus
redoutable d'autres phases à attendre et
cette espèce de d'autres PHAs en
quelques mots ben je pense que ce n'est
pas c'est là que s'arrête la comparaison
avec tout ce qu'on a connu dans le passé
en matière
d'hyperterrorisme je pense que ça n'est
pas un événement que le monde entier a
vécu c'est un cycle qui s'est ouvert un
cycle historique et un cycle dans lequel
le le faible massacre le fort de façon à
utiliser toutes les armes de
l'émotionnel du médiatique des réseaux
sociaux de la cybergerre il y a un
cocktail
invraisemblable de entre père entre 12
pè de guillemets encore une fois de
modernité meurtrière h on va c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut analyser très
froidement et et je pense que on a il va
falloir s s'y atteler sérieusement pas
seul donne la parole mais je voudrais
qu'on parte en Israël puisqu'on a la
chance de pouvoir prendre le pou 4 jours
après cette attaque avec Claire duamel
bonsoir à vous claire vous êtes la
correspondante de France 24 à Jérusalem
mais là vous n'êtes pas à Jérusalem vous
êtes à côté d'ashkellon dans un kibost
justement le kibost yad mord des rail
racontez-nous ce que vous vivez autour
de vous j'imagine les sirènes
retentissent la population est-elle
encore présente ou elle a quitté les
lieux bonsoir oui c'est y morderille
c'est à quelques kilomètres de la bande
de Gaza je suis sur une route en fait un
peu plus loin par là la route est
bloquée puisque les autorités
israéliennes ont bloqué une partie du
secteur autour de cette bande de Gaza
les habitants qu'on rencontre ici nous
disent bien sûr leur grande tristesse
leur colère il faut dire que autour de
cette bande de gazelle il y a plusieurs
kibuts plusieurs localités qui ont été
évacué mais dès qu'on s'éloigne un petit
peu et bien c'est moins le cas hier par
exemple j'étais dans la ville de Sderot
il reste encore beaucoup d'habitants qui
faisaient des choses aussi très simples
du quotidien teles que faire leurs
courses mais bien sûr tout le monde a
ses images en tête meurtrière ses
centaines de de morts côté israélien et
puis et puis aussi bien sûr tout le
monde pense aux otages puisqu'il y
aurait entre 130 150 otages israéliens
dans la bande de Gaza et ça bien sûr
c'est un traumatisme immense pour la
population israélienne alors justement
parlons de de ces otages on sait que la
riposte se prépare le ramass détient
plus de 150 otagees 163 selon le
mouvement islamiste est-ce que l'opinion
fait vraiment pression sur le
gouvernement pour tenter de les sauver
de négocier où au fond elle est résignée
à leur
sacrifice alors bien sûr l'opinion fait
pression mais c'est un petit peu une
situation impossible pour l'État hébreu
historiquement Israël fait toujours tout
pour sauver ses otages dans ce genre de
condition mais là on est vraiment sur un
cas inédit sans comme vous disiez 163
otages selon les autorités du Hamas dans
la bande de Gaza il faut imaginer que la
bande de Gaza c'est extrêmement
densément peuplé il y a 2,3 millions
d'habitants pour Israël il faut
localiser ces otages et puis ça veut
dire une invasion terrestre de la bande
de Gaza et ça c'est pas arrivé depuis
2014 c'est extrêmement complexe ici dans
la zone frontalière on voit les
mouvements des des tanks des chars
israélien qui se dirige vers la bande de
Gaza mais ça fait plusieurs jours que on
dit que cette opération serait imminente
et pourtant elle n'a pas lieu on entend
en Contin continu le bruit sourd des
bombardements ici depuis les localités
du sud d'Israël et puis en retour et
bien il y a des tirs de roquettes vers
l'État hébreux aujourd'hui il y en a eu
particulièrement beaucoup par exemple
cet après-midi sur la ville d'achkelon
et à ce cet après-midi le mouvement
islamiste avait prévenu les habitants
d'évacuer cette ville il copie en fait
une stratégie de l'État hébreu qui fait
la même chose en prévenant des endroit
où il faut évacuer à Gaza alors la
majorité des habitants n'ont pas évacué
ils se sont simplement protégés dans
leurs abris antimissiles merci beaucoup
merci Claire duamel d'avoir été présente
en direct depuis yad mord des rail tout
près d'hkellon à la à quelques
kilomètres de Gaza merci Merci à VOUS
Christopher weisberg il y a des des élus
des artistes une sorte d'opinion
internationale qui s'organise dans dans
votre journal dans le point et qui
demande à ce que ces otages ne soient
pas sacrifi ça sert à quelque chose
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment essayer de
peser dans une opération qui semble
quasiment impossible réussir à négocier
la libération de 100 personnes tout en
bombardant Gaza lave laffront on est
dans quoi là on est dans une manière de
d'engager la société française autour de
la cause israélienne qui nous a tous
stupéfait je crois que l'état de
sidération dans lequel on est tous
tombés samedi matin ressemble où on l'a
dit à ce qui s'est passé le le le 11
septembre et je me souviens je regardais
les les déclarations de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon en 2001 qui était ministre
d'enseignement supérieur et il était
extrêmement clair il était extrêmement
clair il y avait aucune ambiguïté on va
venir une condamnation la politique
aujourd'hui mais je fais juste le lien
avec la tribune aujourd'hui après ce qui
s'est passé et vous l'avez dit je crois
qui est probablement encore pire parce
que quand on discute avec certains de
mes compatriotes en Israël les personnes
ont intégré que ça pouvait rentrer dans
leur maison je j'ai parlé à des gens qui
me disent qu'il cachent des couteaux
dans plusurs endroit de leur maison au
cas où il y aurait un terroriste ce qui
n'est même pas arrivé en France pendant
le Bataclan qui était des des attentats
100 % des personnes des terroristes du
ramas infiltrés ne sont pas encore
arrêtés à l'heure où nous à l'heure où
nous parlons Rodrigo Arenas qu'est-ce
que vous craignez le
plus ce que je crains aujourd'hui c'est
c'est une
escalade tout l'ensemble du territoire
que ce soit dans du Gaza mais aussi en
Israël qui manifestement à la évidemment
la légitimité de défendre de son
territoire et ce que je crains c'est
c'est des crimes de guerre c'est ce que
je crains c'est que c'est que des civils
continuent à à partir de cette situation
ce que je crains c'est que on ne trouve
pas une solution pacifique pour les
années qui viennent parce que c'est pas
supportable c'est pas supportable
d'expliquer à nos enfants qui pour
certains n'ont pas connu le début du
confli israël-palestinien que la
communauté internationale n'a pas réussi
à imposer un un une situation de paix
dans un endroit où ça devrait l'être ce
que je crains c'est c'est de pas pouvoir
expliquer que il y a des hommes
valeureux des deux côtés soit de du côté
palestinien ou du côté israélien qui ont
qui ont pillé de leur vie en fait un
processus de paix et que aujourd'hui
c'est compromis ce que je crains c'est
de pas donner de l'espoir à nos enfants
et c'est ça aujourd'hui qui m'anime et
qui m'a fait prendre les positions que
j'ai prises on va y venir ce mot de paix
alors là celui-là il a été complètement
oublié hein ça fait non non il n'y a pas
de solution militaire au conflit
israël-palestinien plus personne ni
àouri pas moment de le faire mais tout
le monde sait qu'il n'y a pas de
solution milit c'est pas la première
fois qu'Israël va rentrer à Gaza Israël
s'est retiré de Gaza n'oubliez pas d'une
façon unilatérale pour justement ne pas
avoir pour ne pas avoir des citoyens des
civils israéliens et des soldats
israéliens assassinés tous les jours tu
es tous les jours comme comme des
canards pour laisser les Palestiniens se
Perm leur permet de s'autodéterminer
mais mais je je je je tiens à la paix ne
sera pas possible avec le Hamas et et
ceux qui pensent qu'on peut avec une
rentrée terrestre tr 00000 soldats et
radiquer le khamas fait une erreur le
khamas c'est pas c'est pourtant le but
affiché hein on ne pourra pas je vous
dire pourquoi Onra pas on ne pourra pas
parce que le khamas c'est une idéologie
c'est pas uniquement des hommes Israël
depuis la création du Hamas en 1987 a
détruit a tué tous les leader de
idéologie qui vient d'où financé par qui
alimenté par quoi absolument vous savez
encore une chose et c'est pour ça que je
dis que le Hamas ne représente pas les
intérêts du peuple palestinien le vrai
nom du Hamas c'est le mouvement de
résistance islamique c'est pas le
mouvement de btion la pale c'est une
idéologie d'islamisme politique de
djihadisme similaire à tous les
mouvements djihadiste que l'on connaît
ces dernières années qui veut imposer sa
loi dans la région le khamas c'est un
danger pour les pays arabes le Hamas
c'est l'ennemi de l'islam ce n'est pas
uniquement un combat que les Israéliens
doivent mener et pourtant et pourtant
les Israéliens ont joué un peu le ramas
oui non mais je dis absolument
absolument la division mais pour les
radiquer je vais vous dire ce que je
pense qu'il faut faire le khamas se
nourrit de la détresse le khamas se
nourrit de la pauvreté le khamas se
nourrit de l'ignorance le khamas se
nourrit de du désespoir pour l'éradiquer
il va falloir qu'on aide les Gazaouis il
va falloir qu'on reconstruise l'aéroport
qui a existé il va falloir qu'on
reconstruise le port qui a existé on va
falloir qu'on permette aux Palestiniens
de jouir du gisement de gaz et de
pétrole il sont sous les bombes
aujourd'hui hein c'est pas mais oui mais
les bombes vont s'arrêter donc vous
croyez encore la possibilité d'un
processus de Pai les enfants vivent
là-bas
euh Christian maccarion un mot sur
Mohamed deif euh c'est l'homme c'est
l'homme qui serait derrière cette
opération déluge d' laxa c'est lui qui
est en lien notamment avec le Hezbollah
libanais c'est lui qui supervisait
notamment la question des des tunnels
euh qui passe depuis l'Égypte à Gaza euh
qui est cet homme alors on a qu'une
seule photo c'est celle-là euh là il est
très jeune aujourd'hui il a plus de 60
ans euh il a perdu d'ailleurs plusieurs
membres son bras sa jambe un fantôme oui
qui qui est-il qu'est-ce qu'on sait sur
lui c'est c'est le prototype de
l'hyperterroriste de nouvelle génération
c'està-dire que il a intégré tout ce qui
a été fait en matière de terrorisme il
appartient pas à la catégorie précédente
mais il a un ancrage islamiste et ça il
faut le dire et le répéter très fort
parce que l'opération s'intitule
officiellement par le Hamas s'intitule
déluge d'Al AXA et prend pour prétexte
le fait que des colons vont prier
israéliens donc Juifs vont prier sur
l'espanade des mosquées quelle est
l'idée derrière c'est de soulever
l'ensemble de l'islam je ne pense pas
personnellement que ça se produira parce
qu'il y a aucun régime arabe qui a envie
d'avoir le moindre mouvement de soutien
à l'égard du compris avec le hzbollah
Libanais il il y a eu encore des tirs de
roquettes aujourd'hui dans c'est plus
complex dans le nord du Pay c'est c'est
extrêm
complex le Hamas est sunite le Hezbollah
défend Bachar el-Assad le Hamas au
départ voulait abattre Bachar el-Assad
il y a même eu des bisebille au départ
il y a quelques années entre le ramas et
le hzbollah aujourd'hui le Hezbollah
fait un service minimum de mon point de
vue c'est-à-dire oui ils envoient des
missiles à la frontière nord d'Israël
mais ils dépasseront pas une certaine
limite parce que israël va les vitrifier
s'ils vont trop loin n'oubliez pas qu'au
Liban c'est un pays qui aujourd'hui
menacé par un phénomène très simple qui
s'appelle la famine n'oubliez pas que 98
% des céréales consommées au Liban sont
importé de Russie donc un double un
deuxème front à la frtiè au cœur des
institutions libanaises et qui a réussi
à devenir le faiseur de roi à
l'intérieur du système institutionnel
confessionnel libanais si le Hezbollah
va trop loin il va disparaître et c'est
l'ensemble du Liban
concern je crois moyennement à à la men
en revanche le Hamas et tout ce qu'il y
a derrière fait appel à un système qui
est sûrement complexe en matière
d'alliance on a dit l'Iran probablement
mais d'où vient cette sophistication
concernant la barrière bah vous savez
les
Ukrainiens le président ukrainien
affirme que les
Russes sont
également partie prenante dans le
savoir-faire électronique du Hamas c'est
c'est une affirmation que je ne peux pas
vérifier mais il est certain que la
Russie a intérêt à avir un autre front
s'ouvrir pour éloigner la tension
internationale sur l'Ukraine donc ça
prend déjà au au 4e jour une ampleur
internationale considérable et c'est ça
que le Hamas veut il veut pas seulement
mettre fin aux accords d'Abraham et
cornerériser l'Arabie
Saoudite il veut aller beaucououp
beaucoup plus loin et c'est pourquoi je
pense qu'un nouveau cycle s'est ouvert
et et je pense qu'il faut dépasser
l'optique du combat contre le terrorisme
pour aller vers quelque chose de
stratégiquement majeur alors on va
parler de la politique dans dans un
instant bien sûr la communauté
internationale aussi qu'est-ce qu'elle
peut faire les
opinions juste de mots quand même parce
que vous avez dit il y aura un avant et
après 7 octobre en Israël on est tous
d'accord c'est pas simplement en Israël
l'avant et l'après 7 octobre moi le le
différence c'est vraiment les attentats
du 11 novembre où o où la donne a
complètement changé internationalement
vous non non non le 13 novembre
pardonemban Bataclan et et je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec vous c'est c'est un
nouveau cycle qui s'invite mais il y a
un point sur lequel j'aimerais avoir
votre avis c'est celui de la de la
durée de de de cette guerre je
m'explique on sait très bien que les
otages il y en a deux du du Hamas qui
sont pas localisés depuis 10 ans il y a
deux otages israéliens dans les mains du
Hamas depuis 10 ans qui ne sont pas
localisés puis qu'il sont dans les
tunnels et autres sous Gaza euh on est
on est d'accord que les 163
otage quel que soit et vraiment j'espère
qu'on va arriver par la négociation à
les retrouver ça va pas se faire en 2 5
7 10 ou 15 jours on est parti pour une
séquence de temps de de guerre quand
bien même il y aurait
300000 ce moment même oui mais entre
israélien et le Hamas bon mais à votre
avis on est parti pour un un temps long
un temps court un temps éclair parce que
quand quand je vois combien c'est une
monnaie d'échange qu'ils sont capables
de garder pendant des années sans qu'on
soit capable de les localiser ces otages
combien de temps ça peut durer moi
je ça dépendra de ce que veut la
communauté internationale et en
particulier les américains ils laissent
faire ils vont laisser faire les
Israéliens aujourd'hui le président
Biden a dit au Premier ministre Natania
que si Israël rentre d'une façon
terrestre il va laisser faire sachant
très bien que ça va être un carnage mais
quand on verra les photos de Gaza quand
on verra les les la détresse qu' verra
la violence et à un moment donné la
communauté internationale va va dire aux
Israéliens basta on se on se retire et
on régle les problèmes et les otages je
suis préoccupé bien sûr pour eux mais je
pense que c'est une carte d'échange pour
le Hamas il n'a aucun intérêt ni à les
tuer et bien entendu que les Israéliens
vont tout faire pour pour éviter qu'ils
soit tués ça veut dire qu'ils veulent
négocier pour vous il négocie déjà sur
les femmes et les enfants il y a pas
encore un accord par le billet de
l'Égypte par par B l'Égypte par le
billet de l'Égypte surtout leyp qui joue
les intermédiaires parceà un moment
donné le Qatar s'est proposé et les
Égyptiens je pense que les kataris et
les Turques vont rentrer dans la danse
euh prochainement parce qu'ils ont des
des bons réseaux et des bonnes relations
avec avec le Hamas mais déjà il
négocient la libération des femmes et
des enfants qui ont été kidnappé contre
les femmes et et les enfants qui sont
dans dans les prisons israéliennes et je
pense que c'est une bonne chose la
libération de vous savez Israël a libéré
1270 prisonniers pour un seul israen et
donc euh la la vie la vie pour les
Israéliens est fondamentale surtout ce
phénomène là donc les Israéliens vont
libérer moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que
l'Israélien ne libère pas uniquement des
prisonniers moi j'aimerais que
l'Israëlien libère des leaders
politiques modérés de de de du Fatar
pour qu'ils jouent le rôle qu'ils
doivent jouer c'est-à-dire et renforcer
les modérés Palestiniens parce que c'est
eux qui doivent être nos interloc vous
êt un idéaliste toujours je l'espère
madame allez en France à présent on
aurait pu croire que ces attaques
terroristes massives du ramas auraient
été condamné de façon totalement unanime
et bien ce n'est pas le cas depuis 3
jours le communiqué de LFI ainsi qu'un
tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ont embrasé
l'anupe qui s'est réuni ce matin à
l'Assemblée la rupture est profonde
comme nous l'explique Baptiste gargy
Chartier depuis les attaques du Hamas
contre Israël communication brouillée au
sein de la gauche française jusqu'ici la
nup avait déjà subi des tempêtes mais
depuis
72h le groupe se retrouve plonger au
bord de la r là l'apologie du terrorisme
moi je dis non et je dis que c'est un
scandale ce sont eux qui habîent la
nuupes et c'est eux qui doivent
clarifier leur position dès samedi
dernier c'est ce communiqué de la France
insoumisse qui met le feu au poudre ce
dernier évoque une intensification de la
politique d'occupation israélienne des
termes jugés inappropriés indignation
générale illustration Parti socialiste
nous avons été choqués on va pas dire le
contraire nous avons été dégoûtés de
voir que à ce moment-là le minimum
d'humanité commune n'était pas partagé
en coulisse les langues se dél c'est
quand même épuisant d'avoir une connerie
à gérer toutes les semaines se PL du
Parti socialiste on est toujours au dos
du mur à cause de elle F
conclut-il ce matin la France insoumise
dénonce une lapidation médiatique et
tente de circonscrire ce début
d'incendie en 20 qu est la définition
donz has aujourd'hui
comment la branche armée qui aujourd'hui
est responsable de cri de guerre voil et
c'est largement
document dans un contexteendu où chaque
mot est pesé la question de l'unité à
gauche se pose est-ce que vous pouvez
rester au sein de all avec les
ins n'est pas la propriété de
LFI ou de jeanluc mélchon pour changer
l'avenir de la Nupe il faut que sa pète
chez les insoumis lâche un député du
Parti socialiste un cas du Parti
communiste lui enfonce le clou la gauche
sous l'égémonie les fill c'est l'échec
assuré contrairement au PS on n pas
attendu ces événements pour défendre
cette option si l'alliance à gauche est
toujours d'actualité ce soir nul ne sait
encore si ces querelles internes seront
fatales à cette
coalition Rodrigo Arenas le ramas est un
groupe terroriste vous pouvez nous le
dire
mais c'est pas que moi qui le dis c'est
les toutes les instantes naationales le
disent c'est le décare comme tel donc il
y a pas de sujet là-dessus ou vous êtes
un un député insoumis et on peut le dire
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors chez vous
pour que ça soit si compliqué à dire
dire la réalité des faits en fait
d'abord il y a il y a je partage une
partie de l'analyse sur le fait que il y
a des moments où il y a de la solennité
il y a du deuil et que il y a des
moments
de de rassemblement national qui est
nécessaire ça ça a été le cas moi je
suis dép député insoumis vous l'avez
rappelé à juste titre mais je suis aussi
député de la nation et dans ma
circonscription il y a des personnes
juives ou non juifes d'ailleurs qui ont
été profondément bouleversé par la
situation et et c'est mon rôle aussi
d'exprimer ce
bouleversement dans le cadre de mes
fonctions ensuite je pense qu'il faut il
faut rappeler quand même que il y a il y
a pas de sujet sur la dénonciation de la
barbarie du groupe Hamas dans le groupe
de la France insoumiseavez V ma le
panneau elle ne peut pas le dire je vous
je on a une réunion de groupe
aujourd'hui y a pas
ce
point comment ça se passe chez vous en
intergroupe à laanupe sur ce sujetl
aujourd'hui moi je suis pas dans dans
les discussion de internanup puisque je
suis pas membre du bureau de de la alors
au sein des insoumis puisque vous avez
vous leur avez écrit vous dites si les
victimes perdent leur humanité à nos
yeux parce qu'elles seraient du mauvais
côté de la frontière entre oppresseur et
opprimés alors c'est toute l'humanité
qui est assassinée est-ce que ça ils
peuvent le dire pourquoi ils ne le
disent pas non seul et vous vous y
arrivez non seulement je le dis c'est
public maintenant et et tout tout le
monde le sait donc il y a pas de il y a
pas d'ustracisation de ma parole il y a
pas de pression sur mes position vous
allez même plus loin vous écrivez le
ramas ne sert plus la cause
palestinienne depuis longt oui je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
Monsieur bronchan elle ne sert pas
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas servi hier et
je pense que que celles et ceux qui ont
contribué à l'émergence de ce mouvement
dans la bande de Gaza et ailleurs on
responsabilité fa histoireement je P
sois seul sur ce ce point-l je je vous
je pense je pense que vous vous trompez
enfin je vous le dis vous vous trompez
là-dessus la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui la question qui se POS
aujourd'hui c'est est-ce qu'on va avoir
justement dans cette dans cette
humanisation d'un conflit avec des
victimes qui sont là des des crimes de
guerre qui du coup vont disqualifier
l'intervention qui va arriver
inévitablement maintenant vous êtes
quand même très seul vous étiez seul à
la manifestation ils sont où on les
entend pas les autres insoumis vous avez
raison il y a il y a eu il y a eu un
positionnement des lesfi de ne pas
participer à cette manifestation par
rapport aux relations que vous savez
entre le CRIF notamment et Jean-Luc
méloncha et la France à soumise ce n'est
pas mon positionnement moi je pense que
cette manifestation était nécessaire
qu'elle n'a pas réuni d'ailleurs que des
personnes mbres du CRIF il y a eu un
large un large aéropage qui était là
j'ai rencontré Monsieur mouabé pardon
qui pris Nobel de la Paix monsieur
orsena que qu'on n' pas présenter ici il
y a eu une mobilisation assez assez
normale et je pense que c'était notre
place d'être là maintenant il vous a pas
échappé que quand la France insoumis se
déplace dans des rassemblements des fois
ils sont pas bien venus et parfois même
contester et voir expulser Christopher
weisberg vous n'êtes pas dans la nuupe
député de la majorité c'est une faute
grave c'est une faute comment pour vous
bienû c'est une faute c'est une faute
grave le problème c'est déjà je remercie
Rodrigo arinas parce que c'est le seul
député la France insoumise à avoir été
hier dans un moment de Concorde qui
aurait dû être un moment de concorde
nationale et qui aurait dû rassembler
absolument tous les groupes politiques
et vous étiez le seul et pour ça je
soutiens votre courage le problème c'est
que ce communiquer c'est pas un moment
après des attentat ce qui serait déjà
extrêmement choquant qui est
profondément choquant c'est que c'est
symptomatique de la position de ce
groupe
moi je suis dans le groupe
antisémi sou c'est permanent c'est lien
avec le
FP fait qu'elle invite systématiquement
des personnes qui ont des liens avec le
terrorisme c'est permanent
expqup
final notre présidente communi pour dire
que cette réunion ne serait pas permise
mais ce jeull c'est systématique à la
France insoumise et ça crée une fracture
je vous disais tout à l'heure que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a 20 ans il
était dans le camp des républicains et
20 ans plus tard c'est lui qui pousse ce
groupe parlementaire le groupe de la
nupes vers le champ des des gens qui
sont en dehors du camp républicain c'est
ça qui est très grave alors c'est pas
toute la nuupesse parce que vous avez vu
les les prises de distance c'est très
important ce rapidement rapidement mais
il y a une vraie cohérence hein chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon depuis 6 7 ou 8 ans
quand madame obonau se dit ami de Madame
Boutel du parti des Indigènes de la
République qui madame boutelja est une
antisémite notoire que Madame bonau
député de la République soutient madame
boutelja et quand on demande à Monsieur
Mélenchon de sortir de l'ambigué de
dénoncer ce soutien à Madame boutja il y
a déjà 4 5 ou 6 ans monsieur bélenchon
se tait parce qu'il il il vit de cette
ambigué à l'intérieur de son groupe
heureusement heureusement vous êtes là
mais lui ne peut pas sortir de l'ambigué
ou maintenant si il en est sorti il en
est sorti il est clairement du côté de
ceux qui madame boutelj entre autres
pronne un antisémitisme souscouvert d'
antisé bel c'est la la président du
parti ré n demand d'ailleurs la disol
cette proximité on en parlera tout à
l'heure dans un instant Rodrigo Arenas
vous savez c'est l'histoire de la gauche
depuis des dizaines d'années sur les
relations qui a avec les mouvements
anticoloniaux avec enfin on va pas
rappeler ici la guerre froide mais il y
a il y a des liens évidents qui qui sont
mis en place d'un côté et de l'autre euh
la question c'est comment prendre la
hauteur sur tout ça euh moi ce qui
m'importe c'est c'est l'avenir je pense
qu'on on partage au moins ça et et qu'à
un moment
donné si on veut dire ici que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est antisémite je pense que
c'est une erreur je vous le dis vraiment
pour en avoir connaître un peu ce qu'il
dit et ce qu'il écrit si on veut dire
ici que les députés de la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale sont
des soutiens du Hamas la réponse est
évidemment non et que si ce que nos
positionnements collectifs
dans le cadreist peut-être vous essayez
de de séduire des des parts de marché
électoral alors si si c'estoch qui vous
a soumis régulièrement alors je pense
que c'est c'est une une analyse qui qui
pour le coup est cynique de penser que
il y a un électorat pour pas dire
musulman comme on dit ou de banlieu pour
aller plus vite parce que j'entends
aussi cette musique c'est une erreur il
n'y a pas de vote communautaire en
France aucune communauté ne vote de
façon hégémonique c'est bien heureux
dans toutes les communautés a des gens
qui votent différemment de gauche à
droite et je pense qu'essentialiser la
Bonlieu pour pas dire que les Arabes
votent tous unis unilatéralement pour
une position qui
er
terin AR à malheureusement c'est ce qui
se passe malheureusement c'est ce qui se
passe que je
suis n'est pas antisémite il y a quand
même une vraie question qui se pose
pourquoi électoralement on essaie de
pousser quelque chose et
je ce que je c'est je pense que de
lecture n'est pas la bonne sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais elle vous appartient et
je peux moi extérieur je voudrais rapid
par V moi j'ai l'impression écout ce qui
se dit sur jean-lch j'ai l'impression au
fait que il il est rien il est ni
républicain ni à gauche ni à droite si
vous êtes pour la cause palestinienne si
vous êtes pour la paix au Proche-Orient
comment vous pouvez soutenir une
organisation qui a tuer des centaines de
Palestiniens le Hamas quand il ils ont
pris le
pouir
moi je vais être simple d'accord je vais
être simple dans le groupe la France
insoumise il n'y a aucun député qui
soutient le Hamas et je tiens à être
catégorique sur ce pointl il n'y a pas
de sujet il n'y a pas de sujet écoutez
on va pas vous réconcilier sur ce sujet
là c'est sûr beaucoup de choses ont été
dit moment on a bien vu que même ce mot
n'est pas possible dans la bouche de
tous les insoumis on va voir si cette
nupè survit à à cette fracture qui est
profonde et qui est éthique on verra ça
merci beaucoup on s'arrête là merci
messieurs d'être venu débattre sur LCP
vous allez rester avec moi Mario stasie
dans une dizaine de minutes les parties
prix de nos affranchis ce soir Olivier
babo va pousser un coup de gueule sur la
rénovation thermique des logements
Thomas Lestavel nous invite à devenir
secouriste en cette Journée mondiale de
la santé mentale et puis de quoi nous
parlez-vous Stéphanie des piierr ce soir
dans Bourbon Express bis répétite à
myiam après le groupe lot en juin c'est
autour de la France insoumise de vouloir
abroger la R la retraite pardon à 64 ans
on va voir ça dans dans un instant merci
les amis mais d'abord Mario stasie on va
parler de vous de vos combats la Ligue
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme que
vous présidez va bientôt fêter ces 100
ans mais le racisme et l'antisémitisme
sont toujours bel et bien là démultiplié
même par les réseaux sociaux on voit ça
dans l'invitation signée ce soir
elsamondinava on en parle tous les deux
juste
après
[Musique]
si on vous invite mario stasie c'est
pour partager une inquiétude sur la
montée de l'antisémitisme en France un
sujet qui occupera forcément vos
Universités d'Automne ce weekend Mario
stasie vous êtes avocat président de la
Licra depuis 2017 la Ligue
internationale contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme bientôt 100 ans de
combat et toujours le même mot d'ordre
tout n'est pas liberté d'expression que
le racisme est un délit et
l'antisémitisme et ne sont pas des
opinions alors la Licra organise des
formations dans les écoles au sein de la
police et contre la haine en ligne et
c'est peut dire qu'il y a encore du
boulot deux sondages récents en témoigne
neu personnes noires sur 10 disent avoir
été victime de discrimination raciale
autre sondage très préoccupant neuf
étudiants juifs sur 10 affirment avoir
subi des actes antisémites avec une
nouvelle pour eux la menace vient plus
de l'extrême gauche que de l'extrême
droite n'est-ce pas ce que vous pensez
également Mario Stasi il y a quelques
mois c'est contre la France insoumise
que vous avez pris la plume en pleine
réforme des retraites dans une tribune
dans Le Monde vous y accusez LFI et ses
provocations puériles de servir de
marche-pied au RN aujourd'hui alors que
le Hamas a attaqué Israël et que les
insoumis refusent de qualifier
l'organisation de terroriste
vous condamnez Jean-Luc Mélenchon j'ai
honte pour la France ce type est un
indigne de la classe politique qui sort
de l'Arque républiicain alors Mario
stasie existe-t-il un risque
d'importation du conflit en
France réponse l'instrumentalisation à
coup sûr on est en plein dedans puisqueà
partir du moment où on ne nomme pas
clairement les choses et qu'on laisse
dans l'ambigué et fait croire qu'il
s'agit d'un conflit classique de crime
de ou autre on instrumentalise vous
craignez vous craignez une recrudaesance
de l'antisémitisme on a vu qu'il y en
avait un peu plus 20ou vingtaine de
signalements depuis ce weekend la la
plateforme Faros aussi reçoit plus de
signalements sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est quoi crainte de quoi de d'un
embrasement des banlieux à nouveau de
d'une forme d'intifada relégué par les
opinions
mondiales c'est la crainte que de la
banalisation d'un un antisémitisme qui a
toujours existé mais qui commençait à
être de plus en plus inquiétant
notamment à l'université de cette
banalisation on en vient à une espèce
d'éérisation hystérisation une espèce de
haine et et il est évident que la parole
publique la régulation de la parole
publique l'expression de la parole
publique et politique et la régulation
de celle-ci notamment dans le cadre des
réseaux sociaux aura un rôle très
important à jouer si l'on veut contenir
cette prolifération de de de propos
antisémite al toute la question c'est
comment j'ai vu que la Licra allait
porter plainte pour apologie de
terrorisme contre qui contre quoi et
avec quelle chance d'efficacité d'abord
ce sont contre des propos le combat il
est politique c'est-à-dire quelle vision
de la société on souhaite et il y a des
propos il est des propos qui sont
absolument intolérables et d'autres qui
en plus d'être intolérable éthiquement
et moralement sont juridiquement
attaquables et il est certain que nous
sommes poser sur les tweets de du NPA de
LFI de de
de parti des Indigènes de la République
ou du syndicat solidaire ehss et nous
sommes en train la commission juridique
est en train de regarder attentivement
pour savoir si oui ou non comme nous le
souhaitons nous allons déposer plinte
cont c'est efficace la sanction
judiciaire et pénale pe arriver des mois
voire des années après des moyens je
vous ai parlé de la régulation des
réseaux sociaux hein t vous croyez mais
c'est obligatoire mais c'est obligatoire
alors il y a un projet de loi
justementassemblée avec une
transposition DEEC depuis août qui est
transposable avec des des amendes
financières très lourdes qui visent à à
sanctionner les les les plateformes qui
sont complices j'allais dire par
abstinence c'est par absence de réaction
de la prolifération sur celle-ci de
propos hneux antisémite raciste
xénophobe ou autrees d'apologie au
terrorisme bon bien sûr qu'il faut
réguler la parole publique la liberté
d'expression n'est pas totale le racisme
et l'antisémitisme ce n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit pourquoi
voudriez-vous que l'on accepte sur la
toile qui n'est plus d'ailleurs le monde
virtuel he qui est le monde réel la
prolifération de propos antisémite sous
prétexte que il faut laisser la parole
s'exprimerestine vaincra par exemple
pastin V ça doit s'attaquer en justice
Jean-Luc moudin a été extrêmement
courageux tout à l'heure et extrêmement
clair dans son combat puisque aussi bien
il a demandé à son préfet d'interdire
une manifestation de donc oui tout ce
qui est tout ce qui est il y en a une à
Lion d'ailleurs aussi qui a été interdit
en même temps sans tomber dans la concur
victimire Mar
dit on entend aussi dire la tour eelle
ne se serait jamais illuminée pour la
cause palestinienne on entend dire le
blocus de Gaza la responsabilité ou
l'aveuglement coupable de benamin
netaniaou on peut en parler ou pas on
entend dire qu'il y a deux poids de
mesures qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça
au risque de vous choquer même si les
symboles sont importants si hier soir la
tour n'avait pas été aux couleurs
d'Israël le moment demo motion de
d'union autour de ceux nombreux qui
étaient là et de paroles fortes
notamment de Jonathan Afri président du
CRIF grand démocrate ce moment-l aurait
été tout aussi exceptionnel donc
j'allais dire moi la la couleur de la
tour FL ça fait bien longtemps qu'elle
ne me que j'en suis pas très sensible en
revanche sur la politique israélienne du
gouvernement israélien mais évidemment
qu'on a le droit de mais critiquer mais
ça n en rien comparable avec l'action
terroriste à dominable que refuse de
voir notamment Jean-Luc Mélanchon alors
parlez-nous d'un mot pour terminer de
ces Universités d'Automne 13 et 14
octobre prochain qui forcément vont être
percutés par ce contexte là d'autant
plus que le sujet c'est l'extrémisme et
les populisme en Europe et ailleurs et
nous aurons des élus locaux comme
Patrick Hadad de sarcell Jean-Luc moudin
Gill kpel aussi le ministre en charge du
numérique et le dilcra le matin c'est
une réun une une réunion entre les
militants nombreux plusieurs centaines
des sociologues des historiens des
politiques c'est au Havre depuis 10 12
ans et on débat de ces thèmes-là on
réfléchit et pour avoir non pas une
Licra qui simplement dénonce et qui est
vigilante mais aussi une lcra et j'y
tiens et merci de votre propos
introductif dans ce petit film Une Licra
qui propose qui éduque qui forme qui
réfléchit une une Licra actrice dans la
République et que vous présidez avec une
verve passionné on vous entend Mario
Stas vous restez avec moi c'est l'heure
des des affranchis pour leur partie pris
vont vous faire réagir on les accueil
tout de suite l'économie Olivier babo ce
soir de l'Institut sapiens et le
journaliste Thomas Lestavel bienvenue à
tous les deux installez-vous on commence
par bonbon Express c'est l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée alors évidemment elle
a été monopolisée par ces questions de
conflit et et d'attaque terroriste mais
il y a pas eu que ça Stéphanie pierre de
quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir alors je
vous parle ce soir de la France
insoumise qui remet sur la table
l'abrogation de la retraite à 64 ans
rappelez-vous en juin dernier c'est le
petit groupe lotte qui avait étéposé une
proposition de loi en ce sens elle était
soutenue par toute la gauche sen était
suivi des semaines de bataille juridique
entre cette partie de l'opposition et le
camp présidentiel les macronistes
estimaient qu'elle était irrecevable car
non conforme à la Constitution le débat
avait été avorté et bien Mo moins de 6
mois plus tard les insoumis veulent
rejou le match ils vont déposer une
nouvelle proposition de loi similaire
pour qu'elle soit débattue le 30
novembre dans l'hémicycle lors de leur
journée d'initiative parlementaire
Miriam et donc Stéphanie le camp
présidentiel veut éviter de rejouer
évidemment le le psychodrame de juin
dernier oui alors pour éviter
lesécafouillage et d'interminables
arguis juridiques entre majorité et
opposition le camp présidentiel cherche
cette fois à agir au tout début du
parcours de cette proposition de loi au
premier filtre c'est-à-dire celui de la
la délégation du bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale alors cette délégation est
composée de deux députés en Renaissance
reméy reerotte et un Liot pierre mororel
àuissier qui décide de la recevabilité
ou non de toutes les propositions de loi
en juin ils avaient donné leur feux vert
pour celle de lyott feront-ils pareil
pour celle de la France insoumise c'est
ce que veut éviter à tout prix
Renaissance alors la version définitive
de la proposition des insoumis n'est pas
encore connue mais le député renaissance
remyberot de cette femme délégation est
déjà sous pression il nous résume les
critères qui lui permettront de décider
ou non si le texte peut-être discuté
dans quelle mesure elle est gagée
convenablement dans quelle mesure elle
est rédigée convenablement au plan
juridique enfin il y a x critères mais
comme toutes les PPL hein ça ne fait pas
l'objet j'allais dire d'un traitement
particulier sauf que elle intervient
dans un contexte où c'est déjà une un
sujet qui a été abordé et réabordé et
que c'est la première fois qu'on nous
redépose une
PPL une deuxième fois par rapport à une
première PPL qui a été j'allais dire
écarté au titre de l'article 40 et par
rapport à un texte qui a été voté il y a
6 mois maintenantfin merci alors réy
rberotte a pris les devant il a déjà
demandé l'expertise des services
juridiques de l'Assemblée pour trancher
cette question il attend leur avis alors
dites-moi les insoumis eux quelle est
leur réaction ils essayent de prendre
les devant aussi également puisque ce
matin la présidente du groupe insoumis
Mathilde de Panau a mis en garde la
majorité avec cet argument la
proposition de loi insoumise sera
différente de celle de liotte car elle
n'est pas gagée pas financée de la même
manière nous n'avons pas gagé sur le le
tabac cette proposition de loi elle est
cette fois-ci gagée sur les dividendes
donc de soumettre les dividendes à la
cotisation sociale ce qui rapporterait
selon nos calcul 48 milliards d'euros
soit plusieurs fois la somme de la
réforme des retraites
je rappelle qu'en juillet le comité de
suivi des retraites a estimé que la
réforme des retraites coûterait
finalement 9,5 milliards d'euros au
compte public il n'est donc pas
acceptable que les macronistes jugent
que cette proposition loi soit
irrecevable nous serons extrêmement
attentif à ce que de nouveau il n'y ait
pas un coup de force sur les procédures
parlementaires qui nous empêchent de
voter sur l'abrogation de la retraite à
64 ans donc les deux députés de la
délégation du bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale devront de leur décision fin
octobre début novembre s'ils donnent
leur feu vert que feront les macronistes
et s'ils sont pas d'accord entre eux que
se prera-t-il et bien rien n'est clair
préparez-vous Myriam à ressortir notre
Bible à tous ici le règlement de
l'Assemblée nationale voilà le
feuilleton des retraites vous suivrez ça
attentivement merci beaucoup Stéphanie
vous êtes un homme en colère Olivier
babo bah le climat c'est pas important
pour vous en colère contre le grand
chantier de la rénovation thermique
pourquoiiam il y a de scinees colère
comme on sait n'est-ce pas
il y a pas de débat aujourd'hui en tout
cas sur la question de l'urgence
climatique de l'impérieuse nécessité de
mieux protéger notre environnement je ne
plaide pas pour l'inaction l'inaction
climatique je dénonce en revanche les
actions mal conçues qui font perdre du
temps pour celles qui sont nécessaires
alors le problème de la question
écologique c'est que derrière quelques
idées simple auquel on a associé souvent
des solutions un peu simplistes et
uniformes se cachent de redoutables
effets retours l'isolation thermique des
bâtiments en fait partie d'ailleurs
cette question extrêmement simple on
fait donc une isolation thermique à
marche forcée à coup de milliard elle
fait partie de ces solutions simplistes
qui sont en train de révéler en ce
moment leur cruell limite alors
prouvez-le nous en quoi précisément
c'est pas une bonne idée que 2 minutes
pour vous le prouver mais mais je vais
quand même essayer de vous donner les
arguments principaux mais c'est
évidemment une c'était une bonne idée
c'est une bonne idée hein même si on
peut aussi s'isoler avec des pulls
d'autres pays font plutôt ce choix mais
le problème c'est la façon dont on l'a
appliqué et le diable est toujours dans
les détails comment on sait alors tout
partait d'une évidence les bâtiments mal
isolés sont non seulement moins
agréables à vivre mais aussi énergivore
il faut consommer moins d'énergie donc
il faut isoler massivement bon en
pratique il y a plein de problèmes qui
apparaissent on peut en lister au moins
quatre d'abord le DPE le
diagnosticance énergétique n'est-ce pas
il souffre d'un d'un terrible manque de
rigueur qui fait que 70 % des DPE 70 %
seraiit tout simplement faux soit
surévalué soit sous-évalué et alors le
comble il y a des propriétaires qui font
des travaux qui coûtent extrêmement cher
ils se retrouvent à la fin avec soit la
même note soit une note encore pire
voyez pour en terme d'incitation c'est
quand même pas terrible deuxème problème
nous avons fait le choix des rénovations
avec une très haut degré d'exigence lors
des rénovation et ça pourrait se
défendre ça paraît sensé mais en
pratique le coût marginal des derniers
pour d'isolation est extrêmement fort et
il dépasse de très loin les gains
associés les montants auraient pu être
avec beaucoup plus d'efficacité être
investi dans des dispositifs comme par
exemple la géothermie euh pour les
bâtiments du tertièire 3ème idée on a
oublié que le premier problème avant le
gâi le gâi d'énergie c'est l'émission de
carbone or nous avons en France des euh
des des des des énergie qui est
extrêmement peu carbonée par rapport aux
autres parmi les moins carbonés grâce au
nucléaire il aurait été en fait et c'est
le grand drame on se rend compte que ça
nous aurait coûté considérablement moins
cher de développer depuis 10 ans ou 15
ans un parc nucléaire de dernière
génération et c'est ce qu'on appelle en
économie le coût d'opportunité cet
argent qu'on met là-dedans il aurait été
plus intelligent de le mettre ailleurs
et puis la 4ème qui est terrible c'est
l'effet rebond quand on est bien isolé
en fait on chauffe plus du coup il y a
très très peu d'économie regardez
l'Allemagne ils ont investi des
milliards et la consommation énergétique
est restée stable bon d'un mot il va
falloir faire plus court pour laisser du
temps à à votre camarade qu'est-ce que
vous proposez euh ben de essayer de
d'adapter au territoire n'est-ce pas
pareil de comprendre que les situations
sont extrêmement différentes de revoir
cette question du DPE et puis de revoir
les obligations qui ont été fixées un
petit peu bah pour pour des raisons de
simplicité de communication mais sans
trop s'intéresser au Bur de la réalité
merci beaucoup pour la concision Merci à
VOUS Olivier on enchaîne avec vous
Thomas je vous rappelle je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste indépendant
aujourd'hui c'est la journée mondiale de
la santé mentale et vous nous dites
devenz secouriste pourqu effectivement
Miriam alors le covid-19 et les
confinements ont révélé de nombreux cas
d'anxiété et de dépression et vous avez
sans doute des proches qui ont fait la
formation au premier secours pour porter
assistance à quelqu'un qui fait une
crise cardiaque ou un AVC et ben en fait
il existe un dispositif similaire pour
aider un ami un collègue un voisin qui
souffre de de troubles dépressifs
anxieux psychotique ou encore de
problèmes d'addiction et pour prévenir
j'imagine suicide alors effectivement ça
c'est le phénomène majeur et massif en
France une personne tente de mettre fin
à séjour toutes les 4 minutes la moitié
c'est des jeunes de moins de 25 ans et
on déplore plus d'un suicide par heure
en tout c'estes 9000 décès par suicide
chaque année c'est trois fois plus que
les accidents de la route alors comment
ça se passe concrètement cette formation
alors c'est un programme qui vient
d'Australie il a SM dans 27 pays et
aujourd'hui il y a 6 millions de
personnes dans le monde qui l'ont suivi
dont 70000 français et ça augmente pas
mal en ce moment j'ai fait cette
formation le mois dernier pendant 2
jours on a analysé les différents
troubles que j'évoqué dépressif anxieux
et cetera et étudier des plans d'action
très concrets je vous encourage vraiment
à le faire c'est très utile et ça remu
alors j'ai participé par exemple à une
mise en situation avec un autre
stagiaire qui jouait mon voisin de
maison avec des idées suicidaires et je
devais le questionner pour mesurer la
gravité de sa situation et je peux vous
dire que j'en menais pas large alors que
j'étais simplement en train de suivre un
script et alors un conseil à nous donner
si on veut s'engager dans cette voie
alors évidemment de faire cette
formation mais déjà dans un premier
temps çair voir que la clé c'est
d'écouter et ça ils ont beaucoup insisté
là-dessus pendant pendant les deux jours
laisser parler l'autre parler de son
mal-être l'interroger comprendre
pourquoi se sent comme ça c'est déjà
énorme et vous et aussi pouvoir oser lui
demander est-ce que tu as songé à te
suicider alors on va se dire c'est hyper
touchy j'ai peur qu'il se braque ça va
créer de l'inconfort mais en fait le
formateur nous disait bien qu'est-ce qui
vaut mieux entre un petit moment
d'inconfort mais qui va peut-être
potentiellement le sauver un jour ou des
remordes que la personne soit passée à
l'acte c'est vraiment l'enseignement qui
m'a le plus marqué dans cette formation
et je tiens tiens à préciser tout de
suite et les petits sont formels
là-dessus parler du suicide avec
quelqu'un ne va jamais l'encourager à se
donner la mort au contraire pouvoir
enfin exprimer une une telle idée quand
ça nous tarode quand on en parler à
personne ça fait du bien et ça fait
baisser l'angoisse d'un cran et puis il
y a un numéro peut-être que vous voulez
nous donner pour terminer et
effectivement une fois qu'on est arrivé
à ce stade de la discussion il a
évidemment la nécessité de d'orienter
vers la personne vers un médecin et
l'État mis en place le 3114 qui est un
numéro national de prévention contre le
suicide que vous pouvez contacter si
vous-même vous avez av des idées noires
ou si vos proches en non avec ce genre
de réflexe on peut espérer sauver des
vies merci elle est courageuse votre
chronique parce que le sujet il est il
est raide et voilà c'est important d'en
parler savoir s'écouter pardon parfois
c'est pas toujours facile merci à vous
merci pour la concision vous aurez plus
long ces promis Olivier babo la
prochaine fois et Merci à VOUS martio
stasie est-ce que je peux ajouter un
dernier mot très vite un responsable
politique ça doit avant tout être un
rempart contre l'antisémitisme c'est dit
merci à vous très belle soirée
documentaire avec Jean-Pierre gracien
qui commence maintenant à
[Musique]
demain